This Tornado quickly turned massive
after touching down in Johnson County
outside of Indianapolis on Sunday
putting through homes and hurling debris
hundreds of feet into the air all of a
sudden you look out your back door and
all of a sudden you see a tornado coming
toward the ground the Twister ravaged
parts of Bargersville ripping roofs off
dozens of homes including John Keats all
the roof lifted up and all the nail pops
Keith says he saw his walls and windows
crumble around him as he took cover in
his bathroom it was overwhelming to see
your house
uh and and see the outside and know that
you were just sitting there and you
could have been dead officials say at
least 75 homes were damaged there no one
was injured but just an hour south in
Martin County officials there say one
person died and another was injured
after he tornado completely leveled
their home